guys I went on a date this week and I
felt the feminism leaving my body thing
about a guy's guy is he's putting his
card down he's paying for everything and
I really just it sort of activated
something feral in me I'm not going to
lie we went to like another bar and he
went he was going to go to the bathroom
so I was getting prepared to pay for our
drinks cuz he's been paying all night of
course I'm going to pay for the next
round but as he's going to leave for the
bathroom he turns to me and he hands me
his credit card and he goes here's my
card get us
whatever it might be time for me to get
away from all these you know liberal
snowflakes on the east side yes she's
discovered a strange new respect for a
gu's guy she calls him but at this point
all of that respect is based around the
fact that she didn't have to pay for her
own food or drinks